well Canadian from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored Gary lineker
stood his ground against a howling mob
demanding his head over an honestly held
opinion he also stood his ground against
his employers at the BBC as it tied
itself in knots of chaos and hypocrisy
it took them a staggering six days to
resolve Jug's gate six days of turmoil
risking the entirety of the BBC Sports
coverage and the future of his
management over a single tweet
expressing an opinion and the net
results of the whole Ferrar goes a lot
of very angry people and a battered BBC
reputation that will pay the price for a
lot longer than six days not sure what
director General Tim Davey is looking
quite so smug about
one of the joys of this affair is
there'd never been easy solution but
asking Gary to step back off air was I
think a significant thing and now we
look forward with this agreement moving
forward to resolve things and get back
to business as usual
I thought there was much joy in this
whole Affair Mr Dave you match the day
bizarrely Ed with no pundits or
commentary at the weekend after a host
of stars pulled out in support of the
Nikka Sports coverage across the BBC
descended a complete fast as
pre-recorded podcasts and filler took
the place of some of his most popular
shows and that's why the BBC's really
backed down it was about to lose one of
his biggest stars obliterating his
reputation in the process they couldn't
even put together a convincing argument
for why any of this was happening none
of the people bang for lenica's blood
have been able to explain why he's any
different to the many other contractors
who frequently Express opinions like
Apprentice host Alan sugar who blasted
Jeremy corbyn on the front page of the
Sun and made other rather unfortunate
inappropriate jokes well Jeremy Clarkson
when he was hosted Top Gear said
striking public sector workers should be
shot or Andrew Neal who was a BBC star
interviewer and politics host for
decades same time as running The
Spectator
all of these people continued their work
for the BBC along with sir David
Attenborough who talks very stridently
about things like climate change because
audiences like them and they were able
to see the blinding the obvious
difference between the BBC's editorial
stance and the personal views of some of
the people who work for them the entire
Saga has shown an unflattering light on
the BBC Tim Davey looks hapless
perfectly straightforward rules about
impartiality have become an unsolvable
riddle and questions are now
intensifying of the future of chairman
Richard Sharp a conservative donor who
organized a massive loan for Boris
Johnson just before the same Boris
Johnson gave him a job but more than
anything he shot a light unflatteringly
on some weapons great Hypocrites many of
the people crusading for linica's
sacking have found themselves caught up
in the toxic swirl of canceled culture
they normally profess to hate the BBC
could have made a powerful statement for
free speech and Common Sense by backing
than a kid from the beginning instead
it's become well a spectacular own goal
well joining me now is the leader of the
true and fair party Gina Miller and
reform UK leader and talk to you
presenter Richard Tice I'm also joined
by Chief at the writer of the times
Henry Winter let me start with you Henry
always a voice of Common Sense the enemy
of Hysteria as all around lose their
heads
um what's your overview of where we've
washed up on lineke gate
well I think that the broader
perspective is that we should be able to
have grown up conversations in this
country and uh if the government and the
BBC bosses are convinced that a sports
present uh articulating a tweet not a
terribly toxic I didn't agree with his
language on the 30s but you know he's
he's an intelligent individual he's
traveled the world his experience is
quite capable of coming out with a
reasoned argument he's not presenting
the 10 o'clock news so there was no
issue with impartiality but I think
we've seen the best of the the BBC and
the worst of the BBC the best of the BBC
is you're alluding to is the support of
sheer rights and so many other people
for Ian Wright and this is what Tim
Davian this is the worst of the BBC is
the the naivety and arrogance and
entitlement of the bosses upstairs how
out of touch I mean I've talked to so
many BBC staff over the weekend sports
stuff over the weekend who said
management just so out of touch you
can't do that in any business yours mine
certainly not at the BBC so I think Tim
Davis being brought back from America
has been brought back down to earth he's
been reminded that there is this
Collective spirit in his Sports
department so they've come out of it
incredibly well but management really
got to learn some basic skills yeah I
mean and the most extraordinary aspect
of this is you would normally expect the
chairman of the BBC to be getting
involved expressing an opinion but he he
can't because he's under investigation
for wait for it a lack of impartiality
over both his donation to the
conservative party of four hundred
thousand pounds and helping Boris
Johnson facilitate an 800 000 pound loan
when you've got the chairman of the BBC
silenced in a scandal like this because
of his own lack of impartiality as many
see it that really to me Henry sums up
just what a fast has been
I agree I mean peers we're football fans
we're used to dealing with VAR as fast
and this is VAR tenfold there's clearly
an inconsistency in the guidelines on
impartiality and at the end of the day
to use a football league cliche lineker
is a sports presenter he wasn't doing on
Match of the day he wasn't doing it on a
news channel wasn't doing it on a on a
news program and again we're a grown-up
country we should be able to have
grown-up debates and if the government
of the BBC are scared of a sports
presenter voicing an opinion which some
people believe in and they believe in
his principles on his own private social
media accounts then either they need to
look at those guidelines for Freelancers
within the BBC or just grow up yeah I
completely agree Richard Tice uh well
you've lost it's Linux I've been proven
absolutely
BBC and it's like I was here last
Thursday and I said he's brought the BBC
into distribute and he did because they
had zero Sports cover John Saturday all
the others sided with him I was proven
exactly right even Henry's just admitted
he breached the editor why is he back on
air then well hang on he breached the
guidelines he breached the code of
conduct for social media no one said
which is why he's nobody has said that
they're absolutely no they haven't which
is what he's sorry no sorry Richard
Richard Richard
you can't just say things without me
countering that's how we got into this
trouble in the first place the point is
they haven't found him in breach
actually they've actually allowed him
back on air on Saturday because they
recognized that they were up against it
with all the others because he's agreed
with them that all these guidelines need
a review but they haven't found him in
breach they know he breached the gardens
which was set in 2020. you can't keep
telling me that the sky is red when it's
blue do you want me to reread them again
the central media guideline says you
cannot tweet you might say he's in
breach the BBC in its conclusion today
has not said he was in breach
the guidelines you admit they haven't
said that
the point is no the fact is
they've agreed to review the social
media guidelines because that doesn't
mean clear it doesn't mean he was in
breach well I showed you last week
you've just stated for a fact he was in
brief because he used his personal
Twitter account to give a a password the
BBC said he was in Bridge of his
contract well essentially that was why
they suspended him last they haven't now
said he was in breach Gina I mean
filming am I missing something yes you
are no he's not because you're not
missing anything because they're you're
talking about being in breach of the
code which applies to employees he was a
actually he's not he's a freelancer he's
unemployment
no no no the code is actually different
what is most surprising to the interview
I've just heard from Tim Davies is Tiff
and Davies just said so we can get back
to business as usual business as usual
is a whole problem with the BBC and the
way it's been working is because it's
not impartial I think the the the
problem is with all of this week is that
they've shown that they're an
organizational shambles the people at
the top there are biased and shouldn't
be there and to restore credibility is
really important because all of our
shared institutions National
institutions need to have people
trusting it that's what was damaged this
week right but Richard at the heart of
this to me this is very straightforward
given the volume of people who appear as
BBC faces Lord sugar David Attenborough
you know Deborah meaden on Dragon's Den
Karen Brady right all these people have
been pontificating and I think they're
perfectly right but none of them are
actually BBC staff employees now here's
my distinction I think if you work as an
employee of BBC News and current affairs
you should be prohibited from expressing
any public political opinions agree
because clearly you are in direct
conflict but I don't give a stop with
all due respect to Gary and Lord sugar
and all the others and I don't give a
stuff they all have to say about it
that's the good news about this because
basically would you agree with it no I
do agree the point is they've got
themselves under terrible hits
because he brought them into distribute
and he breached their guidelines for
which he was sanctioned and didn't
appear on Saturday that's proven me
right but we look at me hang on we're
looking forward you keep saying
something which hasn't been established
why was it then why was he if he reached
their guidelines why is this pension
being immediately
no he was suspended because
this is really important
suspected for preaching he was he was he
was told he couldn't appear on Saturday
and so all the other yes but he had but
in the statement today there is no
mention of him having breached anything
that doesn't mean he did they're now
doing a big review which is a fudge for
we got into a deep hole we've no idea
how to get out of it agree we'll put him
back on there so he get everything back
on it and then we're going to try and
work this out my solution which is my
solution as well it's just simply to
split using internet affairs from
everything else but in return for which
right Freedom of Choice freedom of
speech I want the freedom of choice of
not being obliged to pay the license fee
for something that I hardly ever watch
that then I think is yeah well you do if
you watch any live platform any live
platform on any device you have to buy a
license fee including if you watch
YouTube on an iPad so look the reality
is we should basically say right let's
have freedom of choice freedom of speech
accept the news that's absolutely fine
but I think this is the beginning of the
end of the compulsory license are you
comfortable having a chairman of the BBC
no who agreed who donated it's
ridiculous okay and secondly you also
have Tim Davey who runs the BBC who was
himself he stood as a Tory candidate
I like Tim Davey Andrew he's a very
smart guy
they've got themselves in a terrible
model but the point is if you breach a
company's guidelines if you bring it
into distribute there has to be a
sanction the sanction has already
happened he didn't appear on Saturday oh
by the way the customer the hang of the
customer hang on more customers watch
without him than with it hang on well
yeah we know that's just that people
would shoot if it's a test card run
right as I pointed out to him actually
uh I think the point Jenna is that he
was not suspended for any discernible
breach of his contract stated by the BBC
he was suspended because of the
incredibly nature of what he wrote yes
and I don't agree with what he wrote but
I absolutely defend his right to have
that kind of I absolutely defend his
right and actually everybody who bangs
the tape by Free Speech should defend
his life but I just want to pick up
something Richard I know you're not very
good at details but let me just um tell
you something about the subscription
service really yeah a subscription
service for the BBC as most free market
tears go on about how are you going to
make that happen when we've got 10.7
words on Netflix it works on Amazon
because they're not a national broadcast
he doesn't have to be a national
broadcast I'm sorry I actually do I do
think the license fee is an anachronism
and I do think it's finished within 10
to 50. I'll tell you why because my sons
are all in their 20s they're just not
going to be feeling morally obliged to
pay a license they don't buy print
newspapers they're not going to pay a
BBC license no but you have to have the
technology to have a subscription you've
got Netflix what are you talking about
because the BBC needs to have something
called conditional access technology
there's 10.7 million people in this
country who what's a BBC on Freeview
there's 10 million people who don't have
super Broadband maybe in the future we
will get there but right now you cannot
invest and convert the whole of the BBC
to Subscription Service it's not
possible at the moment we're gonna leave
it there
um I think you have to accept that you
lost Richard nonsense I've been proven
right he did didn't appear on Saturday
he bought the BBC into distribute I'm
right you you were wrong on Thursday
final question for Henry Winter given
you are the doyen of football experts
are Arsenal going to win the league
Henry because it's looking good
[Laughter]
honestly the the way they've recovered
from Manchester city is just as
impressive with the way you've just put
this Richard character away peace
what had you on Henry Winter great to
see you Henry thank you very much
Richard great to see you and don't worry
you'll bounce back and great to see you
Gina thank you very much